even
there was one time i was in what they
call the predator operations center
which is
similar to what they show on in movies
and stuff where there's
all these video screens in this command
center with all these feeds going on
and there was one time in downtown
baghdad that i watched a dude
pull out two little girls from the back
of his
vehicle the trunk and execute
in the middle of the street and drive
off and he did it
because he was like the u.s can't touch
me
like no one can touch me and he did it
as a statement
in afghanistan i watched a guy a mayor
a a village elder who let his his
village
uh be kidnapped by uh known members of
the taliban
and executed as well and even these guys
like
the you know the guy was executed for
not
cooperating with them and for
cooperating with the enemy
right we were the enemy and so even when
i look at them
like i feel like that's our fault you
know we caused this conflict we caused
this strike
we weren't going over there to bring
peace we were going over there to bring
a sword
right we were doing this in in
such an unhealthy way
and no matter what i look back at i
don't
feel like we were noble
you know we didn't do we didn't do it
good and
and right and in my second shot when the
child
ran into the field of view like i
remember my supervisor
so it was called out on screen that uh
dog
uh that was a dog that was on the field
view
i asked my pi how did that whole second
shot start like
like how did that that that whole
mission or that that whole operation
specifically began um so
usually you know things when when the
shots happen
it's not like an immediate thing usually
there's a build-up
they had been following uh two
high-valued individuals
and they had thought that they were in
this farmhouse and they had been
monitoring traffic in and out of this
farmhouse and eventually they thought
that well
the two guys that we're looking for are
in there so
uh we're just gonna take the shot and
that had been that
that decision had been made before i sat
in the seat and so when i had
when i had been sitting when i had come
to sit in the seat
uh i didn't know about that
decision right so i had just been you
know it been
the guy before me had been watching this
for eight hours the guy before him had
been watching it for eight hours and
then launch the aircraft
to this mission and i had just thought
well i'm just gonna be the
guy that just watched this mission i
thought that usually they're gonna act
when they say that they're gonna action
a place it's gonna they're gonna send a
group of rangers in there
to capture these dudes and figure out
what they're doing
and so when they finally made the
decision to shoot it was more like well
we don't want to send anyone in there
we're just going to shoot these guys
and while i had
you know i had been feeling quite
loathsome
of myself i thought that you know
i'm in this position i might as well
follow through
um
and so it was an l-shaped building
and everything was going down and you
know it's typical
run the checklist point the
uh we estimate they're probably in this
area of the
building pointer crossers at this corner
uh turn on the laser and that was it
right and i'm
sitting there just mindless
and i had a lot of drama going on with
my peers like my peers were really dumb
and uh stuck in high school so like i
said before one of the problems is
there's no discipline in the drone
program is because they take a lot of
high school kids who still stuck in high
school the drama
how old were you at the time 19 uh
actually i was 20. okay just i turned 20
in november before that
and my second shot happened right
either right before or right after
valentine's day i kind of get
confused but it was at that point in
time and this girl that i was
i had dated in the squadron if i were to
give any advice to people in the
military
never date anyone in your squadron it
just causes a whole bunch of problems
and this girl was causing problems for
me she was i broke up with her and she
wanted to sleep around and she was
saying things
really nasty things about me i tried to
apologize to her
i tried to make right with her my
grandfather had just been he's like just
be kind to her
and she just caused more and more drama
and
so i was feeling all that as well and
when the ch we're so we're sitting there
on this building and they give us the
order to shoot
and again you know these people over
there they hear
the sonic boom the missile impact they
they know what's going on
so i think that this person who the
child who ran into building was told
that if you ever hear something like
this run into shelter
right and that was probably the closest
shelter building that they had
right and if it was early in the morning
like most of shots happened
that person was probably taking care of
their animals because there was a there
was a little barn that had a couple
sheep and goats or whatever
in it and maybe a few cows and this
person could have been
taking care of doing the early morning
chores and here's this
this sonic boom go off and run to the
building
um so you saw this this small person or
child
run into the building bef after you
pulled the trigger
yeah after we pulled the trigger and
about six seconds before impact
like um and it was probably even sooner
than that it just seems like the time
goes off but the
the sonic boom whatever was hit this
area first and the person ran into the
building
or was i'm not even sure if they got
into the building they were just
running into it as the missile struck
um and so like i
i was devastated um when i went to my
supervisor i was like look
man this is not right like and he's like
send me an email about it just
you know just ignore it just you know go
with the official report and i was
you know they teach us one of the core
values of the
air force is integrity first service
before self and excellence and all we do
and in that regard we we failed there
was no ac there's no integrity in what
we're doing there's no excellence and
there was no service
um you know service degree service to
violence is
maybe the best i can come up with and
i reviewed the tapes i reviewed the feed
and everyone basically told me to just
shut the [ __ ] up
you know shut the [ __ ] up we don't want
to hear it
and so i did you know i
i bitched a lot while i was in but that
was because i was the best at what i did
you know i would tell people that were
being wasted that were being used that
this is a waste of time
um but so what did they do they just
made me work more
it just put me in a gcs and made me
do the job more um
and it was it was really devastating to
me it was
it crushed me um with all the
the drama that was happening behind the
scenes um
i it killed me
it really it it killed who i believed
that i could be
you know it killed the dream that i had
for
for who i wanted one second i'm gonna
shut the door okay
um and
i keep trying to tell people this and
it's like i s i'm speaking
to deaf ears right
um when i remember when i first got out
uh of the military i started hanging out
i met a vietnam veteran who
recognized the signs within me and he's
like you need to go to therapy about
this
but i had a top secret clearance at the
time and i knew
that going to therapy put your top
secret clearance in
in jeopardy actually i think i still
have my top secret parents now that i
think about it
um how do you still have it how do you
still have a top secret clearance
because i got it renewed right before i
got injured and it's uh
never news for 10 years um and it hasn't
been 10 years
actually it'll be 10 years and how did
you get injured
um i had a uh i have a traumatic brain
injury
i had a 170 pound log it dropped on me
during a training exercise
oh um broke my skull in two places and
uh compressed my spine and bounced off
my shoulder i tried to catch it
um which was probably the
worst idea that i could have had but i
thought i was tough
um and so i mean then that was
that was actually the reason why i blew
the whistle was was
because i was on my deathbed and i was
facing
the consequences of a
tarnished soul and i wanted to
that the whistleblowing was essentially
my deathbed confession
if if we want to look at the my wrestler
background
what is a whistleblower you know it's a
referee someone who says timeout
you know we're doing the wrong thing and
i had a lot of compassion for people in
the drone program like
i knew that i knew what they were doing
and what they were going through
and the the sickness that was happening
but after i came out and started
speaking
it was like my entire everyone turned on
me
you know in in the worst fashion like
you know i have a i have a
i have a stalker you know now his name
is rick wright nearson he has this blog
who talks he he says all sorts of [ __ ]
about me he's
in his blog he calls me uh he says that
i'm part of a death cult who used the
powers of the people that
the souls of the people i killed to give
myself supernatural powers
stuff like that all sorts of weird [ __ ]
and this guy was
he claims to be have come from the
program um
and they say all sorts of [ __ ] my my
call sign in the military was
church because i was a good church kid
you know and i'm no longer religious
uh in fact i i disdain religion above
all things i think that it's
uh it leads people astray more than it
leads people to the
light um and even in the military they
say that we're
we're doing this for god and country the
when i went
uh when i was in the third sos they made
me go see
a chaplain because i couldn't see a
therapist uh due to my clearance and the
chaplain was like god wants you to feel
this way
god wants you to kill these people and
it's all right and like
they were trying to use my own religion
against when
my grand my great grandfather was a
minister for his whole life and my
grandfather was the one who raised me
and he would totally have been you know
i didn't get to confess to him anything
before he died before he passed away
but uh i know for a fact my grandfather
had been like this isn't
this isn't the god that i talk about
it's so
it's so crazy to think that the greatest
superpower in the world of the united
states
is has 19 year old high school students
flying around shooting hellfire hellfire
missiles
at apartment buildings or into
wedding parties weddings funerals
you name it you name it we've done it
you